mercredi dernier c'est une énième fêtes
clandestines à paris qui a fait parler
si les occupants étaient une trentaine
et non pas dégrader les lieux c'est
l'intervention d'un voisin célèbre qui a
fait prendre une ampleur considérable à
cette affaire nicolas sarkozy a décroché
son téléphone pour dénoncer une fête
clandestine car ce qu'ignorait la bande
d'amis revenu dans le 16e arrondissement
de paris pour un tournage c'est que
nicolas sarkozy était leurs voisins si
la fête a lieu après le tournage sans
que la production de ce dernier ne soit
averti d'un tel événement et forces de
l'ordre sont intervenues pour faire
cesser la musique raï son nombre après
une plainte d'une voisine l'ancien chef
de l'état qui passaient dans la rue en
rentrant du match psg bayane au parc des
princes aux alentours de 23 heures
auraient constaté le tapage nocturne de
ton âge en question est en réalité une
émission sur les influenceurs produite
par guillaume genton alors fêtes
clandestines arrêté par nicolas sarkozy
guillaume genton est il coupable il est
avec nous ce soir pour tout nous
raconter
alors cette soirée elle a fait
énormément parler des articles dans le
point dans le parisien que s'est il
exactement passé
j'aimerais dire aux gens dont vous
racontiez nos téléspectateurs d'abord ce
qui s'est passé et après alors on aura
également si nicolas sarkozy a téléphoné
lui-même à la police ou pas vous dire et
où laurence ça y est et bernard montiel
alors alors je loue effectivement une
villa pour les besoins d'un tournage
alors vous l'avez cette villa louée à
villa montmorency qui est un quartier du
16e arrondissement de paris
et la villa mitoyenne de celle de la
maison de nicolas sarkozy d'accord ce
tournage c'est un tournage qui suit le
quotidien de cinq influenceurs qui sont
tous majeurs french house exactement qui
sont des célèbres du temps au coeur mais
on les suit dans leur quotidien donc à
une équipe de caméraman de deux
caméraman plus de personnes de la
production qui est présente de 10h à
environ 20 heures ce mardi soir nous
terminons en tournage à 20 heures les
équipes rentrent chez elles
je suis chez moi évidemment c'est après
l'émission où j'étais là jusqu'à 21h20
je rentre chez moi et il se trouve que
les influenceurs qui je le rappelle sont
majeurs et ont un manager qui lui aussi
est majeur ont organisé une soirée
clandestine
de combien de personnes de 50 personnes
cinquante personnes scandant la personne
je vous le dis parce que j'ai fait un
tournage à vérité et toute la vérité
il y avait toute la jeunesse dorée
parisienne d'accord c'est qu'ils
actionnaient story non mais je vous le
dis parce que je suis un service
similaire
non mais lucky la jeunesse dorée et qui
fait jean s'est passé et je vous le dis
parce que pourquoi parce qu'on tient en
dégâts importants j'ai fait un tournage
similaire il ya pas longtemps dans une
très belle maison avec des rappeuses et
avec plein de mecs de quartier j'ai eu
aucun problème
il ya eu aucune fait rien aucun
débordement et là pardon mais ils nous
ont trahis
ils ont trait à la production ils m'ont
trahi puisque derrière mon dos ils ont
organisé cette soirée je n'ai évidemment
absolument pas organiser leur cette
soirée donc vous êtes parti mais les
équipes de tournage parts à 20 heures
19h21 qu'alors arrive les gens les gens
ont été revus je les suis lendemain moi
je suis ravie à 5 heures du matin j'ai
vu toutes les vidéos parce que je
connais quelqu'un qui était à cette
soirée qui les a envoyés à partir de 21h
ils ont lancé des invitations à tous les
jeunes qui sort bandés dans des soirées
clandestines et ils étaient 50 au total
la police a été appelée une première
fois
la police est venue il y avait trop de
bruit ils leur ont demandé gentiment
d'arrêter la soirée et ne l'ont pas fait
la police est venue vers 23 heures je
crois d'accord ils sont revenus à 2h30
du matin il y avait vingt policiers en
fait faut savoir c'est un quartier qui
est privatisée donc il ya des voix qui
est baptisé
ils ont coursé les jeunes et la soirée
ne s'est pas s'est pas arrêté là fini
vers 3 4 heures du matin ces projets
n'ont jamais parlé soirée je n'y ai pas
participé
alors juste c'est une production pour
ses beats oui voila je sais je suis
également je le dis dans la boue coeur
cette émission ah oui c'est vrai je la
prends aujourd'hui c'est donc c'est un
peu vous qui avez fait la fête à gré non
mais chez les policiers il faut savoir
jeunes à paris par là dedans à morgat
parce que contrairement à ce que par
précaution j'ai fait signer un contrat à
tous les influenceurs présents dans la
maison et à leurs managers particules et
qu'il était interdit de recevoir une
tierce personne ne sait ce qu il avait
fait donc ça j'ai montré sa aux
policiers et ils peuvent rien faire
ensuite voudrais dire aussi que sur ce
genre de tournage
il ya beaucoup de tournages avec des
maisons avec des personnalités
l'intérieur des candidats etc
il est très rare que la nuit on laisse
un vigile ou une nounou
quand il n'y a pas d' équipe de tournage
donc s'ils ont envie de mettre le feu à
la maison s'ils ont envie de faire
n'importe quoi malheureusement après ça
nous retombe dessus et c'est normal
parce qu'on est la production mais c'est
pas de notre faute c'est tout alors vous
allez nous dire si pour vous qui
aujourd'hui est coupable ou pas et je
voudrais savoir aussi si
nicolas sarkozy a vraiment été la
personne qui a appelé la police juste il
ya une petite question laurent seillier
je vous la pose il ya beaucoup de
téléspectateurs qui dit pourquoi nicolas
sarkozy a eu le droit d'aller voir le
mali est rentré chez lui après 19 heures
alors ça je ne connais pas la raison là
non parce que c'est ça en fait
l'histoire mais je crois qu'en fait je
vous le dis je je pense quelle erreur
selon nicolas sarkozy je crois que
nicolas sarkozy n'a jamais appelé la
police c'est ça l'histoire exactement ce
alors c'est quoi l'histoire pourquoi ça
serait retombé sur nicolas sarkozy
il ya une soirée avec des gars à côté de
chez lui et c'est devenu nicolas sarkozy
bientôt ça va devenir nicolas sarkozy a
fait de soirée avec cinq ans
d'intervalle dans une semaine ça va être
là je tente renouvelle tout à coup il
souvenu mme fox chez dc en train de
danser qu'est-ce qui se passe oui il
faut toujours une bonne occasion pour ce
faire nicolas sarkozy mais c'est
incroyable parce que c'était à côté de
chez lui l'ont dit que c'est lui qui
avait dénoncé pas qu'ils revenaient du
match il y avait déjà la police sur
place qui était en train de régler une
partie de la sphère et en aucun cas
c'est lui qui a appelé la police mais il
est beaucoup plus vendeur pour un
journaliste pour faire un buzz et son
article de dire que c'est nicolas
sarkozy qui a effectivement appelé la
police sans vérifier apparemment puisque
ils ont même retiré l'article
et ça a été démentie formellement par
l'attaché de presse de nicolas sarkozy
c'est sûr que c'est pas lui ça a été
démenti formellement dans la dèche et de
presse donc d'accord se l'imaginent quoi
on monte sur ce type de magie et puis de
toute façon regarder la concordance des
horaires puisque comme vous le dites il
revenait du match donc après qu'il l'ait
surveillance autour de son domicile
c'est normal d'aider politique c'est le
cas pour les anciens précédemment menacé
alors il est ami avec nasser donc il va
avoir un match parce qu'il a invité par
nasser mini va quand même dans
l'illégalité
alors est-ce que c'est dans les dégâts
et c'est ce que site illégal ça juste
pour savoir il ya je ne sais pas du tout
moi je sais plus qui ce qui est légal et
ce qui est légal bien sûr c'est que je
n'ai rien à voir dans cette affaire
puisque je ne sais pas je ne sais pas ce
qui est légal ce qui est légal ou non
mais justesse que c'est légal ou illégal
dit la vérité
moi je pense que ça fait partie de sa
fonction son ancienne finlande alors
guillaume genton en tout cas ce qui est
sûr c'est que depuis le début du
confinement du couvent il ya plein de
personnalités qui vont voir les matchs
de foot les rails à caen terme d'image
c'est un peu dégueulasse et pas que des
politiques on a vu par exemple anne
hidalgo choix c'était le psg les limites
sinon elle est injuste bockel pour
épargner
ils sont tous seuls en tribune et c'est
avec des motifs des vélos d'après lui il
est monsieur premier dock juste bernard
montiel nicolas sarkozy a fait ce qu'il
avait à voir avec cette histoire alors
en aucun cas nicolas sarkozy a appelé
qui que ce soit il rentrait du match
effectivement sont les voisins qui ont
déjà appelé parce qu'il ya eu un bordel
terrible et puis surtout les os les
officiers de sécurité du président parce
que c'est quand même un ancien président
qui est toujours protégé il a droit
cette protection là qui eux-mêmes
voulait baliser le terrain quand ils
rentrent que soient tranquilles parce
que les jeunes par et il était
extrêmement bruyant et extrêmement
alcoolisées alors justement berg et au
japon je me tourne vers vous selon
plusieurs sources deux policiers
auraient même été blessé par une porte
cochère et ont porté plainte
l'auteur des violences a été interpellé
et 17 personnes ont été verbalisées pour
non respect des mesures sanitaires en
vigueur dites nous tout alors d'abord
évidemment je n'étais pas assez de
soirée mais de ce qu'on m'a dit la
version des policiers c'est qu'il ya
effectivement une course sage loges les
bus on a même des images ils ont été ils
ont coursé donc les membres de la soirée
dans une allée les membres de la soirée
sont rentrés dans la maison et
apparemment ça c'est la version des
policiers y aurait une porte qui se
serait refermée brutalement sur la main
d'une des policières qui auraient été
blessées la version qui m'a été rapporté
et quoi qu'il arrive c'est inadmissible
je tiens à le dire vraiment c'est que
dans la course
une policière aurait chuté dans des
marchés se serait fait mal voilà ce qui
est sûr c'est que les jeunes n'avaient
pas à manquer de respect aux policiers
ce que vous leur avez parlé puisque vous
êtes leurs producteurs qui secoue leur
avait dit alors en vrai de vrai moi je
les ai des fonds c'est parce que je
trouve quand même genre quoi bâti tout
bas on est les jeunes voilà bon essayer
de faire ça mais elles font un petit peu
des jeunes voilà qu'elle est petite il a
fait une parie que vous vous rendez vous
mais en vrai bon mais je leur ai dit que
c'était un manque de respect parce qu'en
fait c'est pas que ça n'engage pas que
personnellement il ya une production
derrière il ya des dégâts financiers
ce qu'ils ont ils ont cassé des choses
dans la maison évidemment dégrader la
maison j'en ai gardé la maison dégrader
la maison plusieurs milliers d'euros de
dégâts
[Musique]
akai datant d'il ya plusieurs musées en
milliers d'euros de dégâts dans la
maison issa qui paie c'est moi vous
c'est drôle et c'est moi voilà oui ça
vous coûte pas plus cher
pas d'inquiétude c'est le principal donc
d'un côté je les ai un peu défoncé parce
que parce que je trouve ça mal d'un il a
sauté je je je les ai défoncé mais pas
trop parce que je les comprends et je
comprends le fait qu'ils soient au bout
de leur vie qu'ils aient envie de faire
la fête mais quand même l'escouade il
est responsable
guillaume excusez moi mais vous êtes à
la fois responsable et chambly colas a
reconnu gré des infos j'ouvris alors
nicolas sarkozy n'a pas appelé
directement il s'est retrouvé là ils
étaient présents revenant du match au
moment où il ya eu la bousculade
et effectivement il a salué toutes les
forces de l'ordre ils étaient là lors
après laurence dit d'ailleurs il n'était
tellement pas impliqué que le parisien a
retiré son article faut savoir qui est
un scandale au parisien en ce moment
nicolas sarkozy via son attaché de
presse a appelé directement le numéro un
du parisien lui a dit je veux que
l'article soit retiré l'article a été
retiré et la société des journalistes du
parisien dit c'est une première jamais
en retire un article parce que toutes
les informations il faut quand même le
dire du parisien était bonne
non sur le fait que sarkozy a appelé
direct aux kiwis alors goûter vidéo leur
silence parisien il disait des
intermittents sont verbalisés oppression
les intermittents dans la débandade dans
la soirée ces jeunes là ils sont pas
payés parce que c'est un documentaire
sur leurs vies déjà première chose
deuxième chose on a aussi lu dans la
presse que le tournage avait un terrain
où étaient interrompus il n'a pas été
interrompue parce qu'ils étaient
contraints et forcés de changer de
maison ils n'ont pas changé de maison
donc avant d'écrire des conneries qu'ils
prennent leur téléphone les seuls qui
m'ont appelé c'est le point voilà alors
alors jusqu'en nicolas sarkozy il a fait
retirer l'article parce qu'elle avait
une erreur sur lui en plus tôt
concernant wii anormalement bas il a
fait retirer l'article le les
journalistes du parisien massivement
désiré juste cette connerie mais tombent
entre les mains
j'aime pas les mêmes gilles verdez juste
elle a raison c'est le titre et c'est le
mec sur lui dois de retirer
vous êtes vous êtes toujours en train de
défendre tout le monde surtout le coeur
et la raison ce sont des barbons c'est
vulgaire mais ce sont des [ __ ] akli la
clique c'est plus vendeur de dire que
c'est nicolas sarkozy et c'est plus
vendeur de dire que c'est un membre de
l'équipe de tpm paix qui organise or
j'ai même pas la vérité mais non mais
moi je suis ma responsabilité
la vérité c'est que ce sont de jeunes
influenceurs qui ont organisé une soirée
clandestine sous effectivement notre
responsabilité d'accord mais ce sont des
[ __ ] à cliquer de m et nicolas sarkozy
était pmp en titre des articles honnête
j'aurais eu on aurait fait pareil que
arrêté alors oui mais non est exact dans
ce conte de ce congrès en direct exacte
et voilà après voilà mais gilbert d'être
et si c'est insupportable que vous
défendiez tout le monde à chaque fois
sauf ceux qui ont besoin d'être défendus
et la guillou il a l'air sincère et la
bestia j'ai envoyé les coupables mais
ayant que j'entends il est responsable
oui maintenant mais je lui ai dit très
gentiment mais à ce que je sache vous
vous êtes peut-être producteurs mais
vous n'étiez pas là celui qui gère
directement c'est guillaume il dit oui
je les ai défoncé enfin un petit peu et
je les comprends et aux non dits oui
mais je vous donne mon opinion moi en
tant que producteur guillaume je trouve
que vous êtes responsable ce qui s'est
passé peut-être que vous ne les avez pas
assez serré contractuellement ok vous
avez tout bétonner
mais peut-être que vous saviez que
c'était des jeunes qui avaient un risque
et qu'il aurait fallu faire très
attention à ce qui est pas une famille
dé gêner non alors que selon les
informations du point
le témoin dit vous ne tuez louer cette
ville à guillaume foyer du 6 au 21 avril
pour cinq personnes
oui chaque nuit et cinq techniciens
prévient présent que le jour où ayant le
contrat de location est vraiment été
vrai visiblement interdit de mettre de
la musique dans les jardins page
j'aimerais ça c'est vrai c'est vrai
dalmat fait visiblement ce soir là rien
n'a été respectée ce qui est est ce que
les voisins étaient en colère où et
comment ça s comment ce fait-il donc que
voilà que nicolas sarkozy se retrouve
dedans c'est juste parce qu'il passait
par là et ils ont dit vrai il y avait
nicolas sarkozy moins d'un sursaut on
m'a dit mais à juste titre que nicolas
sarkozy était extrêmement mécontent
après c'est vrai ils ont fait n'importe
quoi ils ont invité 50 personnes ils
n'ont pas respecté le matériel c'est
comme une villa qui est extrêmement
luxueuse faut faire extrêmement
attention y'a des cautions qui sont très
chers
ils sont amis de la musique à fond à 3
heures du matin ou alors n'importe qui
au dire on a des images exclusives de
cette soirée je vous le dis alors il
fait nuit il fait nuit dans mes shows
d'ici là donc on voit pas grand chose
mais ce sont les seules images de cette
fameuse soirée de cette fameuse nuit on
vous montre ce qu'on a un voile à
guillaume voilà on est les seuls à avoir
c'est
image forcément regarder de quoi parler
point de cancale par les parisiens
[Applaudissements]
voilà donc ces images on a c'est qui qui
a filmé sa quelques uns étaient présents
à la soirée qu'on m'a envoyé moi j'ai
reçu ces vidéos à 5 heures du matin en
me réveillant qui disent que c'était
chez moi que j'ai organisé la soirée et
que j'étais qui m'envoie les vidéos à ce
que vous avez été entendu par la police
on ne note société est entendu par la
police ou d'accord vous pour qu'est-ce
qui vous ont demandé
baky et qui étaient les organisateurs de
la soirée qui a participé est ce que
vous aviez anticiper ce genre de choses
ce à quoi j'ai répondu oui puisqu'on
leur ajustement est justement jean on
l'avait anticipé
je leur ai fait signer un document pour
leur interdire de recevoir des gens
après vous ne pouvez pas contrôler ce
que font les gens quand ils dorment la
nuit qui sont censé dormir quand ils
sont aux toilettes etc
c'est les aléas d'un ton âge il est je
le saurais si tu étais producteurs
qu'est ce que vous risquez sais pas je
sais pas si je veux garder son calme
j'aurais d'esprit si vous avez des
sanctions je les prendrai mes moyens
mais il ya pas déconner ils ont déconné
bien que vous lâcherai pas là dessus
bien sûr c'est vrai que j'étais très
très énervé je le dis aux
téléspectateurs c'est vrai que j'étais
très très énervé le matin quand j'ai
appris ça parce que je n'étais pas du
tout au courant de ce tournage qui a été
fait par notre société par une des
filiales de notre société de production
et c'est vrai que j'ai gueulé assez fort
voilà je le dis aux téléspectateurs je
sais que j'ai vu on vous a dit quoi a
dit la vérité on vous a dit cyril est
énervé oui bien sûr vous savez on m'a
dit non mais moi c'est quoi les mots
exactement moi qu'on sache on dit la
vérité il venait à pété un câble on dit
quoi vous allez m'a dit qu'on allait
filer les policiers non voilée on m'a
dit que vous aviez pétanque
oui j'ai moi ce qui m'énerve là dedans
c'est parti je vous le dis parce que ces
cinq jeunes qui sont très sympathiques
au demeurant mais bien sous tous
rapports
voilà c'est déjà d'or en plus j'adore
j'ai vraiment et je vous le dis c'était
joli ces cinq jeunes qui vont faire un
programme sur ces 8
sachez qu'on était en compétition avec
tf1 avec même dire on va le dire avec la
boîte d'arthur oui ça voilà pour les
produire ils ont préféré venir chez nous
c'est vrai avec webedia qui fait un
travail fabuleux webedia voilà c'était
il était chez de là bas je leur ai dit
on va faire un programme télé ce
programme va se faire ou pas oui va se
faire le tour de la snrt très bien et
désolé d'avoir géré les voir pour leur
part les gars là je vous le dis on fait
pas des racailles mais voilà et ont
pleuré je suis désolé voilà il
son majeur ya pas deux poids deux
mesures non plus pour tous d'accord
chalon sans me tombe dessus d'accord
avec géraldine ça fait un scandale
d'état avant l'inter si d'accord avec
vous d'un coup ses coups tordus toutes
les personnes qui faisait sorte que
j'aime ça c'est clair en elle que qu'on
leur reproche
et ils ont raison majeure ils ont 18 19
20 ans il se retrouve dans une très
belle maison tout seul où ils ont décoré
la donne on n'y a pas deux poids deux
mesures ils sont vraiment vraiment
dévoilé comme à faire toute une histoire
mais n'interdit de la com dit géraldine
sur chalon sont et sur les coûts et le
dira pas non corses et des jeunes qui
sont sympas non ça je suis désolé ça
tout haut eh oui
non mais ce qui est pas mal surtout les
oui et les non je n'y ai pas malheur il
est pas manqué de louer une baraque dans
le coin le plus protégé et le plus
privilégié paris le plus cher ce sont
des impasses privé où il ya que des
villas où il ya que des gens friqués
si tu veux alors quelle mauvaise idée
d'aller louer une baraque avec des
jeunes mais il a rien à cacher mais
c'est une impasse ça résonne vachement
et parce que les gens riches sont les
arthaud avec sarko avec aghlabites au
goût de la belle en jeu alors je vous le
dit guillaume je vous le dit bernard
montiel pose aussi une question que tout
le monde a posé tout le monde a dit
pourquoi avoir loué cette villa pour
cette production alors qu'il y a
l'ancien président qui est juste à côté
oui il ya plein de gens très imprudent
dans la rend donc c'est ok là bas voilà
pourquoi écoutez nous on cherchait une
ville à cette vie là elle était à louer
des villas de ce type là bas c'est quand
même cinq personnes faut les loger il
faut faire des types chaque personne là
bas il y en a pas non mais bon il est
nommé le concept faut savoir de la
french house à marcher quoi sont des
influenceurs aussitôt regroupés dans une
villa de luxe c'est vrai nom il a raison
vers une villa de luxe nai oui cette vie
là elle était franchement magnifique et
bernard il faut savoir que toutes les
émissions tournées dans les villages y
compris les enjeux les marci etc
tu te doutes bien que c'est pas demandé
dans des favelas
j'ai bien vu ce sont de belles maisons
si oui ben ouais ce quartier dioulakro
vous n'avez pas été bateau plus loin
dans des tons j'ai pas mal maison non
mais si monsieur sarkozy veut avoir la
maîtrise de toutes les personnes qui
sont autour de nicolas sarkozy je
connais je connaissais tu mets la mort
aussi toutes les villas sont juste à
côté
pourquoi il la loue alors ah mais non
mais pourquoi vous y avez été pourquoi
vous n'avez était d'enchaîner après vous
avez peut-être un peu plus loin avec un
truc à dire +10 points avait un certain
budget avec certains critères on a dit
ça parce que c'est sûr que ça coûte
beaucoup plus cher monsieur vous aviez
terrible mais on l'a fait pour la fée
pour la qualité des missions vous
d'avoir une très belle maison on a
appris cette maison les autres elle
était éclatée pardon j'ai pris cette
villa et mata
c'est un d'alès a man for bardon et
c'est un classique sur les tournées
cette villa elle et comment elle est
bizarre de l'extérieur elle l'est mais
en fait il ya pas vraiment dexter ce qui
est montré secret d'avant n'avez pas le
droit de filmer le lancer principe le
savez ou celui que je crois que dans
cette ville a ajouté je crois qu'il ya
eu un meurtre un jour si si je vous jure
que c'est vrai non non je vous dis donc
pour vous dire cette villa pour mauvais
karma dans ce cas là je vous le jure que
c'est vrai et je vous dire que c'est pas
une blague
je crois que le jardinier où j'étais
plus de cette vie là à tuer la maîtresse
de maison
non mais avec son fils et sa mère non
mais je lui reconnais même s'il vous
plaît je vous dire que c'est vrai dans
l'aveyron ou lentilles mais je voyais je
pense que cette maison voilà vous auriez
dû me demander
ah oui c'est pour me demander les trucs
comme ça c'est difficile quand on quand
vous êtes en train de faire la
production et à l'auxerrois après soir
il faut choisir les vida faut choisir
les intervenants fauthoux bousdira
demande si c'est bien cette vie là je
vais vérifier je vais enquêter mais je
vous dis je crois que c'est ça la vue
sur la ville son mari mme goody on
passera en version crime classique dans
ce genre de tournage que c'est souvent
des jeunes que ce soit les candidats
prêts à l'it de télé réalité ou là des
influenceurs c'est un classique et des
débordements c'est un classique que les
voisins peut être agréable en ce moment
en ce moment c'est vrai que tout le
monde est sur les dents et chez les gens
qui nous regardent ils disent pourquoi
eux ils sont privilégiés et nous on est
comme des cons je pense 1,30 mètre carré
à 6-2 en à fait m'excuser auprès des
voisins et après tout et vous êtes
responsable à 45% non à 55 % c'est bon